[Music]
the
the evidence is uncontradicted that the
president used taxpayer dollars to ask
the ukrainians to help them cheat an
election and the complaint that I've
heard all right people it is February 6
2024 I'm Dave Rubin this is the Ruben
Ruben report and you may notice we are
in a different Studio that's right we
are live from rumble's brand new studios
here in the swamp in Washington DC yeah
it's happening people uh as you guys
know Rumble and locals have studios in
Miami and Sarasota we've shot some stuff
uh at on location at debates and things
like that but this is a permanent Studio
open as of today I think this is the
first full live stream that they're
doing uh we already shot an interview
with Senator Rand Paul this morning I
was over at the capital uh with Jim
Jordan this morning we're going to show
you some video of that uh probably
tomorrow uh there were a lot of trans
Flags over there these people have taken
over and they want to swap out your
genitals who knows what's going on over
there uh anyway it's total coincidence
that this studio is opening today in the
midst of what is a crazy day here in DC
with this border fight because everybody
is in town basically every Senator every
Congress person is here they're fighting
out this border thing we're going to
dive into that later today I'm
interviewing Ted Cruz chip Roy Marsha
Blackburn Tom Cotton we are trying to
get Democrats we have requested many
Democrats including John fedman who I
personally reached out to we would love
to sit down with some Democrats I'm not
that scary so if you're a Democrat or if
you're a supporter of a Democrat or you
know a Democrat tell them Dave rubin's
in DC he's willing to sit down with you
guys and I'll treat them as respectfully
as I would treat anyone else uh but we
are going to dive mostly into to the
Border stuff uh for today you may be
wondering why we cold opened you with
that Eric swell famous farting moment on
MSNBC and the reason is I took the team
out for dinner last night we went to a
stake joint and check out who was right
behind me over there that's right that's
Eric swalwell having dinner and he the
guy smells because he's farting all the
time we're going highbrow today uh but
all right let's uh let's Dive Right into
everything I think really really what
set what will set us up kind of for the
for the Border nonsense is that everyone
in this town seems to agree on one thing
publicly or privately which is that
something is not right with Joe Biden so
Joe Biden gave a speech this morning and
we're going to play this for you and
there's a little bit of confusion here
let's see if you can figure it out for
yourself if not I'll help you on the
other side people have fled guilty you
know right right right after was elected
I went to what they call a G7 meeting
all the NATO leaders it was in it was in
the south of England and I sat down and
I said America's back and meeran from
Germany I mean from France looked at me
and
said uh said you
know what why how long you back
for and I looked at him and the and the
chancellor of Germany
said what would you say Mr President if
you picked up the paper tomorrow in
London times and the London Times
said thousand people break through the
House of Commons break down the doors
Two Bobbies are killed in order to stop
the election of the Prime Minister what
would you say I never thought about it
from that perspective what would we say
if that happened in another democracy
around the world all right there's a
couple things going on there first off
has one eye closed for some of it the
ball chin thing is happening but that's
not really the error the error of course
is he says Mand from Germany uh he's
referencing jacqu Mand who was the prime
minister of France uh but that was a
while ago that was 1981 to
1995 and he died in 1996 and Joe Biden
is saying that he saw him shortly after
he was sworn in to be president so that
that kind of the reason I wanted to show
you that clip I know we can always show
you Joe Biden doesn't know where he is
and he's stumbling and mumbling and
wandering off into the forest but
everyone in this town is kind of like
that's not the guy that's really in
charge we don't know everyone has their
own theory on who really is in charge
and then you wonder why we get these
crazy bipartisan border deals that
nothing makes sense and it's spending
for Ukraine and a whole bunch more it's
like the guy who's supposed to be in
charge is actually uh not in charge so
let's actually jump into uh
some of what's going on here there is a
bipartisan Senate deal on the border now
remember they have been telling us for
months and months on mainstream media
and basically every Democrat from Biden
to cala to mayorcas on down has been
telling us there is no border crisis
right finally then in the last couple
weeks mostly because on Twitter videos
of Just rampaging people through the
Border are getting out there finally
they're admitting there's a bit of a
problem so then they get a bipartisan
that means is a Republican senator and a
Democrat Senator uh so in this case it's
Oklahoma's Lanford and Chuck Schumer
from New York he's the Democrat
obviously they come together with a
bipartisan border deal now we don't need
any extra deals here because we don't
need any extra laws we have all the laws
on the books to close the border the
Democrats have decided not to do that uh
they've got this bipartisan deal when
they say bipartisan what that really
means is they're both screwing us both
parties screwing us over uh here is
James Langford again one of the authors
of the deal on with Jak Tapper
discussing what this deal is all
about
it's a bit of a beautiful Moment In that
clip because it's what they're not
really telling you that really is the
story I mean that it's just a setup
right Jake Tapper is bringing up Elon
Musk and lanford's got his canned line
about the Teslas with Elon
but Elon is bringing up a good point
that we all know there is definitely
some sort of policy or plan with the
Democrats to bring in all of these
people they are putting stress on the
system but the hope is if they give them
enough stuff they will become Democrat
voters I don't think that's a grand
conspiracy I think it's fairly obvious
and most people are kind of saying it
under their breath in this town but
they're going after Elon because Elon
has bought Twitter and allowed most of
us to know that there's a problem here
in the first place uh Elon then
retweeted a video of Greg Abbott on Fox
News and of course this really this all
escalated about two weeks ago because
Greg Abbott decided that he was going to
protect the border of Texas because the
federal government refuses to do their
own job so Elon Musk retweeted a video
and he wrote absolutely true and let's
show you that video from Fox right now
Biden says he needs Congress uh to give
him the power to do whatever he needs to
do to secure the border the fact is as
we all saw from what president Trump did
the president of the United States has
the power I must emphasize this uh there
is an obligation there are laws in the
United States uh that require the
president to deny illegal entry of any
illegal immigrant and then if they do
get into the United States he has a
legal obligation to detain those illegal
immigrants Joe Biden is failing at both
of those duties and that's exactly what
gives Texas The Authority uh to make
sure that we can step up and secure our
own border and protect our own State
through self-de okay guys I'm going to
throw back to that CNN James Langford
clip in just a sec I'm told there was no
audio on that new studio we're working
out some technical details thanks for
bearing with us but just quickly in
reference to what Greg Abbott is saying
there look the laws are on the books we
have a border the president is supposed
to defend it and once we have all the
illegals here they are supposed to be
rounded up and kicked out the the very
notion of a sanctuary state or a
sanctuary city is not legal in and of
itself and we now know that plent of
people who are living in these cities
who are seeing their services go to
other people and their tax dollars go to
other people like the 53 million dollar
worth of credit card uh dollars that
they are going to give to the illegals
in New York City we covered that
yesterday people are actually starting
to be pissed so okay let's throw back to
that clip uh this is James Langford
senator from Oklahoma on CNN with Jake
Tapper and they're really watch how
they're making this more about Elon Musk
than they are making this about the fact
that about six million illegal people
have entered the country in about two
years on Twitter or X by Elon Musk who
posted quote the long-term goal of the
so-called border security bill is
enabling illegals to vote it will do the
total opposite of securing the Border
unquote now I know that Elon Musk is not
an expert on illegal immigration or the
Border but he has a huge megaphone um he
does explain what he's talking about
here is he wrong uh well I I think he
needs to go back to doing the 2 million
Teslas that are currently being recalled
right now to be able to focus in on that
no it's not focused on trying to be able
to get more illegals to vote that's
absurd uh in the process on it it is
against the law for anyone that is not a
citizen of the United States to be able
to vote in the United States in any
federal election that remains so
obviously we're not dealing with that
okay so I already recapped that for you
so we don't have to do that again but
really what the fight about what the
fight is about right now is whether this
thing is going to pass and whether we
need more laws more regulations more
power to the swamp that I'm in right now
to do the very things that it's not
doing that it has the power to do right
now and it's not doing if we just had
more laws to do the things that we're
not doing would they do them I think not
anyway there is a big fight of Bruin
because James lford who again he's a
republican this is a bipartisan deal
they're trying to push through uh he's
getting a lot of crap from right-leaning
people who were like this whole thing is
BS so Lankford tweeted this the Border
emergency Authority has been the most
misunderstood or maybe just
misrepresented parts of the bill some
people have said it would mean 5,000
people a day are coming into the country
every day this is absurd and untrue a
guy by the name of Steve Dennis who is a
Bloomberg Congressional reporter he
wrote I don't see anything in the bill
that legalizes 5,000 people cross ing
illegally into the US every day that's
just the threshold for title 42 like
Authority with more teeth than title 42
and then Kirsten Cinema who is is she
now an independent is she technically an
independent was a Democrat saw the how
crazy they are she is now technically a
independent she tweeted out this this
provision is getting woefully and
perhaps purposely misconstrued the
Border automatically closes when migrant
encounters reach 5,000 that does not
mean that 5,000 migrants are permitted
to enter the country every day so you
might be hearing all of that and go Dave
we've been watching the show over the
last couple days you've reference this
5,000 migrants that can come in
illegally every day but they're saying
no well actually I am right and when we
had Brock open up his trusty iPhone and
multiply 5,000 times
365 days a year that is about 1.8
million illegals and yes they will be
allowed in here so unfortunately for
Lanford and Cinema and uh this Bloomberg
report order yes you can now be fact
checked in real time on X which is
exactly what's happening so here's Greg
price who's an actual journalist he
wrote this with actual evidence from the
bill itself not only does this bill
codify 1.5 million illegal border
crossings into law but the Border
emergency that automatically gets
implemented at 5,000 Crossings per day
in a week can be overturned by Joe Biden
and in case 1.5 million illegals isn't
enough it also locks in Green Card
giveaways through 2030 uh he continues
great news for everyone coming onto our
Southern border if you cross it
illegally get arrested and mayorcas
Stooges decide you entitled to
protection they will now be able to give
you an automatic employment
authorization thanks to Mitch McConnell
and James Langford so okay so this seems
to be the key part of this right
now we have all of the laws to stop the
illegal immigration the very issue that
they kept telling us for months and
months wasn't happening now they're
acknowledging it's happening and now
they are literally from Lanford on the
Republican side to Kirsten Cinema on the
independent side but all the Democrats
because the Democrats want more of this
illegal immigration they are all telling
us that this 5,000 illegal immigrants a
day thing is not real it is real it is I
mean we literally just showed you the
part of the text that is in the bill it
is real and I've been asking some other
people while I'm in town here uh anyway
it sounds like this thing is Dead on
Arrival does not look like it's going to
pass uh in the house and here is Mike
Johnson the Republican leader of the
House saying this thing ain't going
anywhere we we did read through it Laura
and it did not take long to realize that
this is Dead on Arrival there's no way
we could bring this through the house
the Senate expects us to pass a a bill a
piece of legislation that you just did a
great job dismantling here what it would
do is actually further incentivize
illegal immigration it would not resolve
any of the problems not reform in any
meaningful way the broken Asylum system
the broken parole process and all the
things that have created this
catastrophe and by the way meanwhile it
further owers the very cabinet secretary
who designed and created this mess they
don't follow federal law why would we do
this anyway but the bill itself would
actually do more harm than good and
that's why we've said it's it's a
non-starter over here in the house Mr
Speaker are you going to be able to stop
this bill we're going to do everything
within our power I when I say it's Dead
on Arrival I mean Dead on Arrival um we
we we're going to have to work this
every other angle that we can and ensure
that we're taking care of our
responsibilities here the House
Republicans are dug in and ready to do
that testing out all sorts of things
today uh look the point of all of this
is everyone knows it is unnecessary uh
by the way there's $60 billion in this
thing for Ukraine what that has to do
with our Southern border and immigration
nobody knows I just had ran Paul here
who was really going off on that think
we're going to post that for for you uh
tomorrow but yes this thing it does not
sound like it will uh pass well it
doesn't sound like it's going to pass in
the Senate we'll see about that but it
is not going to pass in the house for
sure but again that then leaves us in
this weird position that we're in right
we're at the beginning of February right
now we have an election in November so
does it do they just keep rampaging
through the border and then the hope I
guess if you're a sane person who wants
America to continue is that Trump wins
in November and by January of next year
which is 11 months from now then we can
start reversing all of this how many
more million people will have gotten in
by that point I mean that that really is
the question but before we continue I
want to talk to you guys about gravity
defier shoes guys I want to tell you
something that's been making my days is
a whole lot easier gravity def Fire
Shoes these shoes are something else
people everyone knows Dave rubin's a fan
of comfortable Footwear but these shoes
take it to a whole new level more than
just shoes they're basically clouds for
your feet I'm not kidding and a double
blind study by Olive View UCLA Medical
Center and published in the Journal of
the American podiatric Medical
Association participants experienced 85%
less knee pain it's the most powerful
shock absorption system put into a shoe
gravity defier has patented Verso shock
technology it's like a mini trampoline
in your shoes whether you're strolling
through the park running errands or even
lounging at home these shoes have got
your back or I should say your feet even
better they're stylish you get both
comfort and style that looks good and
feels great and here's little extra love
for our listeners use code Reuben 30 for
an exclusive $30 off 150 or more yeah
you heard it right a little gift from
Gravity to fire to your feet experience
the miracle that is gravity to fire
where Comfort meets Innovation and now
back to me all right so what is Joe
Biden doing you might wonder right we
played the clip of him last night the
guy thinks that the now dead president
of France is the current president of
Germany this is a bit of a problem uh
but Joe Biden we've not only seen
precipitously that his cognitive
abilities have crumbled in the last
three or four years but almost all of
the policies that he is instituting
right now are the reverse of the
policies that he was running on remember
when he was running the whole idea was
oh it's just old Joe Biden he's a
moderate he'll stop all the crazies
right he'll stop the onslaught coming
from the progressives he's done no such
thing right I mean he's completely
exacerbated it and escalated it uh to
prove that theory uh here's Joe Biden
back in 20 when he was running for
president my question to you is if an
individual is living in the United
States of America without documents and
that is his only offense should that
person be deported that person should
not be the focus of deportation we
should fundamentally change the way we
deal with
things congratulations Joe Biden you
have fundamentally changed the way we
deal with immigration now we can have
some debate as to what we do with the
people that are here here right so
there's Joe Biden I I'll sort of give
him credit I suppose there he's saying
look if somebody got here illegally and
they're here and they're working and
they have no other criminal history or
anything else he's saying we shouldn't
Deport them now that's Up For Debate but
like that's not really what this is
about what the real issue is is that he
has opened up the Border Trump closed
the Border he was called racist he
wanted to build a wall and have Mexico
pay for it Trump has subsequently
admitted that Mexico was never going to
pay for it there was no mechanism there
but the point is the elite ilal border
crossings we showed you a graph on this
last week when Trump was President
illegal border crossings were about
300,000 a year they've hit over 2.5
million a year so they've basically 10x
almost this is a bit of a problem and
then of course what happens is the
mainstream media ignores it while it's
happening in Texas and Arizona when do
they get upset they get upset when they
make it up to Martha's Vineyard when
they make it up to New York City or when
they make it up to America's murder
capital Chicago here is Chicago mayor
Brandon Johnson he's very upset cuz the
guy's under a lot of stress he's got you
know his his citizens are all shooting
each other now you've got these people
coming in and they're kicking people out
of homeless shelters uh and he's got
other problems I have children who
attend schools who have soccer games
y'all you know you all are asking me as
if I'm not a parent in this city I get
it I'm mayor I get it but you're asking
me to give you a date and I have to
court do you understand that you have
not had a mayor like me I get that I
have a wife have children they have
schedules and plus we still have Public
Safety that we have to address we still
have the unhoused that we have to
address I still have a budget that I
have to address and I'm doing all of
that with a black wife raising three
black children on the west side of City
of Chicago I am going to the Border as
soon as
possible that poor man he's got a black
wife and black children how are we
asking him to have a job at the same
time dude do you know what you signed up
for you're the mayor of Chicago the
place where they kill can we get the
numbers how many people were shot in
Chicago this past weekend we like
getting those numbers you're the mayor
so what you have to take your kid to
soccer I got a black wife well how the
hell do you want me what what do you
what do you think I'm doing over here
like okay other people with black wives
have jobs like you got to do your
freaking job but you can see this is
it's such a perfect example of what
progressivism has led itself to right
like or what It ultimately leads to
which is that you get a bunch of
incompetent buffoons doing all of the
worst things and then he's also the
victim right he's the victim cuz he has
to take his kid to soccer and that's a
pain in the ass oh wow low numbers out
of Chicago this weekend only two people
were killed in Chicago this weekend by
gunfire only 11 shot that's got to that
has got to be an all-time low that is
well I guess he's doing something when
he's taking his kid to soccer apparently
that's nice anyway the point of all of
this guys is that more and more people
are waking up I don't think the
solutions are going to come from the
government it happens to be nice to see
that Greg Abbott is doing the right
thing in Texas and now he has 25 other
Republicans doing the right thing I
don't think the answers and the solution
are going to come from this town I will
ask many of the Senators and congressmen
uh that I sit down with over the next
couple hours about just that uh but more
and more people are realizing there is a
problem and that actually that's the key
thing at the moment right because a
month ago most people didn't realize
there's a problem now the fact that Greg
Abbott did this it escalated it into the
mainstream we got this bipartisan deal
it doesn't look like it's going to
happen but more people are talking about
what is obviously a problem I thought
this was interesting this is a professor
at Penn State University basically
explaining why the Democrats are trying
to overrun the country with illegals on
the B migration like on the border right
border patrol like close it down a
little bit like whatever but we don't
but it just keeps going and it makes me
think the people that are running the
shop must for some reason want to have
this unfettered immigration flow
including including undocumented workers
because otherwise we would just pass a
law that says you can't do that like or
we would tell these like uh the the
authorities the people who would be
deputized the people are going to rent
it to folks like pick them up off the
streets and do something it's just
bizarre to me that we just let it happen
and by we I mean the people that are
making the laws and enforcing the laws
cuz it's not the three of us it's
somebody else it's people that are like
holding the strings up here and they
don't so we got this constant
immigration flow and we got about 11
million undocumented workers in the
United States right now undocumented
people all right so with that Professor
it's good to know that there are still
some Sayan professors at some Sayan
universities what he's saying is that
there is a giant multinational shell
game being played right now we are
moving people all over the globe we are
moving people all across borders and you
cannot pretend it is not intentional
right so you don't have to think uh that
Joe Biden is doing it intentionally
because we don't know who's I mean every
literally everybody in this town that
you talk to nobody thinks he's running
the show everyone knows it you don't
think he's running the show I don't
think Dr Jill Biden thinks he's running
the show etc etc we all get that but the
point is it has to be intentional at
this point you know there were a lot of
people for months and months oh well you
know it's like the Democrats like
immigrants more and you know whatever
and then and then more and more people
have realized as you just see thousands
of people Rampage through the Border
again they're always fighting age it's
always men 25 to 35 where are the women
where are the old old people etc etc
then you start realizing oh whoever is
in charge whoever is pulling those
strings as he reference they actually
want this and the question is do they
want this because they just want our
cities to be overrun and our services
destroyed so they can usher in some some
new system do they want it so that you
get all of these people on the Dole and
once you're on the Dole you end up
voting for Democrats pretty much forever
see black people people in America that
probably is it that probably is it uh
but guys there are some answers and the
answers again are not coming from this
town you know where the answers are
coming from they're going to come from
individual states that are just going to
say enough is enough so that's what Greg
Abbot did in Texas and that's what Ronda
santis is doing in Florida they have now
unveiled a piece of legislation in
Washington and and I think you'll people
are starting to point out you know what
a farce it is to basically say that you
only shut the border down once 5,000
people a day come illegally which is
about 2 million a year so that's
basically legalizing illegal immigration
uh and there's so many other things that
are wrong with it but I just think
taking a step back what it shows me is
it just shows me the contempt that these
people in DC have for American taxpayers
uh I mean the amount of money they want
to send uh all around the world the
amount of money that they're uh saying
that they're going to use for Border but
it's really going to go to facilitate
more of the problem I just think the
whole thing is a farce the fact of the
matter is the president has the
authority to secure the country's border
you don't need a new piece of
legislation to do that just do it uh and
if you did it I think a lot of people
would be pleasantly surprised that you
did it but what this is this is just
another dogin Pony show out of
Washington it will not solve a problem
uh it will just exacerbate uh the
problem even further and so I don't
think it's likely has much of a chance
uh but you know you never know what the
folks that we've got in Washington DC
nowadays and we are live from Washington
DC you get the point I I'll even go a
step further the president uh has the
duty to shut down the Border there is an
invasion we have real problems remember
that covid thing what if these people
are bringing illnesses into the country
we have no idea so you can either sit
there and think that this bipartisan
group of people who are writing more
laws even though we have all the laws on
the books to end this thing right now it
could be over by the time I finish this
sentence but it will not be uh you think
that they are going to write more laws
to close the border while at the same
time they're somehow connecting it with
another 60 billion from Ukraine on top
of the God knows 100 billion that we've
given Ukraine already and no one knows
where any of that's going and we're
protecting their borders and we're
paying their pensions and a whole bunch
more
I say all of this to tell you that
although I will talk to all of these
senators and Congress people today I
don't sense that the answers are coming
from this place I sense that the answers
will come from independent states doing
what's right for their citizens and
actually that is very congruent with all
of the ideas that our Founders had in
the first place so maybe that is the one
maybe the one good thing that DC is
offering us right now is not just a new
studio so I guess there's two things we
got a new Rumble studio and also that
they are showing that everyone in in
this town is so inept is so corrupt that
actually we will be forced to govern
ourselves the way the founders intended
in the first place wouldn't that be
pretty sweet guys this was a bit of an
abbreviated show but we've got 8,000
more interviews today so thanks for
bearing with us we got a postgame show
coming up on locals Ruben report.
locals.com if you want to join us people
of the internet will be delayed slightly
today we'll be live at
130 p.m. uh with we're doing it with
Marsha Blackburn people of the internet
with Marsha Blackburn okay people of the
internet with Maria Blackburn that's
going to be interesting uh that will be
exclusively on Rumble uh new Twitter
account as you guys know Ruben report
show if you want to catch some show
clips uh oh and we leave you a cold
close in case this show wasn't scary
enough about the immigration uh Invasion
here's what the future will look like in
America's cities
goodbye I got it on this
speach